see what we have on youtube instead oh
this guy i haven't seen this guy's a
john suckers such a nightmare fuel this
dude is so he's sitting in his bathtub
with his guitar which is
vegan he's nightmare fuel in his clothes
this wasn't necessary
the title of this video is it's been a
long time since i got laid
oh boy he's just coming right out with
it now huh yep here it comes
come on mike let him get through the
song let him get through the song
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] boy are we just we're opening up
right with the right we're going
right into it huh this is up there with
ani defranco's white people are so
scared of black
people
oh have a [ __ ]
of sex i do not what does it feel
like to fight i forgot
in cells rise up oh boy you know rice up
what did i say guys you can go back and
you know you could go like for instance
rice if i may
you could go to uh like patreon.com
we're not sorry
nice you could go there for five bucks a
month you can listen to our archives
we've been covering this guy since that
long ago since almost the beginning
yeah so you guys got to go back into the
archives when we first covered this guy
what did i say about this guy said he's
this is his desperate way he's going to
do the vegan thing and the animals thing
this guy smacks of a [ __ ] male
feminist desex desperate
like sex pest and i knew it was gonna
come out someday
i called it and i'm still shocked at how
bad it was on the nose this is like i
thought it'd be a little more subtle i
forgot it's been a long long time
[Music]
this is great
[Music]
[Music]
can i say something yes honestly
best song he's ever made on ironic i
don't even mean because of the funny
lyrics
you notice how when he's being
pathetic and he's he's doing the whole
like this guy's a great uh
psychological study in male feminism and
the whole male
lefty kind of mentality because a lot of
them do it because they're just trying
to get a chroma [ __ ]
and they pretend like i'm an ally on
this on that and they're all these weird
creeps right
so this dude if you listen to his old
stuff
it's always like i am a vegan you should
not eat meat
uh like he puts no feeling or passion he
puts no
actual energy into the songs because
it's fake it's not coming from a real
play he's not feeling anything when he's
just
he's just being like robotic and going i
also like
lgbtq people and you may
save the panda bears and he's just
saying [ __ ] that he hears at these
rallies and he's trying to
nobody cares but this is the first time
this is they're called they're called
checkers here
he's playing chords he's actually
singing because
this is this is the this is our first
glimpse into honest john
this is he he's feeling this you know
what i mean
this is 100 as opposed to the ulcer you
should not eat meat
vegan is the way to go lettuce is
blibbly
bp grow a compost garden and it was like
okay but you're not
it was very robotic and now he's like
he's actually
like please suck my dick because i need
my dick sucks
like all of a sudden he's harmonizing
humanity wait a minute what
oh [ __ ] this is the uh
oh man i want to hear one of his other
songs just so we could complain
[Music]
speciesism
it's there's no melody there's not a lot
of effort put into it because he's not
feeling it this
he's feeling this dude
well i mean there's still people that
are going to be around you at certain
points
you still want to you don't want your
crotch to smell like fajitas
fajitas for some big macs offers what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
since i got
[Music]
it's been a long time
i'll pay for it too because we should
pay to have him do a legit studio like
get a recording of this oh
find out what cities and we get a band
we find a
studio session fan and go can you just
help him tighten up the song and just do
a couple of takes and
amazing i would pay to have that done
and then of course i get a piece of the
royalties somebody said what happened to
cousin joe jesus that's not cousin joe
see these two things i like to profit on
john
white kid's depression and black kids
criminality
he's from vancouver there you go get
take great we'll get that taken care of
[Music]
some people have a lot of sex i do not
what does it feel like to [ __ ] i
forgot it's been a long long
time since i got laid i feel really bad
for alternate universe joe bluth yes
yeah you're right but sorrow job
some people have a lot of sick side
tonight
what does it feel like to [ __ ]
it is amazing that all that virtue
signaling didn't work nah i know
this guy this guy is a beautiful like if
this guy were doing a [ __ ] like a
long con andy kaufman bit
it would have been brilliant but instead
this is just a legitimate case study
in what a leftist incel looks like if
they post
status updates over time and this like
seriously
somebody said earlier i think toon squad
was like wow merch is really hyped about
this
you don't understand this has been a
long-term case study for me and royce
and this is like
being a scientist and having so many
things
and then finally one day like the
[ __ ] thing sprouts
or you know some schizophrenic you're
studying stamps the right subject and
you're like that's
we're figuring it out now that guy's
dead that sucks but we
were getting closer for science so yeah
i'm very excited you don't think this
song is good
get this is the best part about this
song get an acoustic guitar and have
somebody that sounds like chris cornell
sing it
it would be a [ __ ] hit no seriously
something he's being serious
think about it you get you get get a
guitar get someone like sounds like
chris cornell to sing this song
acoustic it would be a huge hit you get
any talented person
yeah like seriously you get even like a
low like there's a lot of musicians that
listen hey guys cover the song
make it your own i'll post the link in
there it's called a it's been a long
time since i got laid by john
sackers s-a-k-a-r-s
i'm going to reach out to the band
parmaly and see if they'll do it nice
it's the only band i know when they ask
guys hey hey marvin i got that new sound
you boys are looking for
listen it is sure that's not a phone
sir that's an iron
why did i do that why is there an iron
in this bar
mike i'm look i want you to look at this
and i think you're right look at those
eyes
that's somebody who meant every word
that they said meant every word they're
gonna say and may do it
may well potentially could potentially
could i mean he's a vegan he's
gonna overpower sure but may attempt
you may attempt you're right can you
imagine a regular sized girl just
putting her hand on his head and going
would you
stop but imagine if he was loaded up
with protein and more testosterone i'll
eat beans
beans have protein shut up actually i
just thought about that what if he ate
meat and was full of testosterone i just
realized oh he probably would have
gotten laid by now yeah he would have
had sex
yeah he would have sex he'd be like wait
what am i doing i'm kidding i could
easily have sex
because that's the problem too he's
vegan he's all run down so he's just
gonna keep taking the soy boy
approach whereas when you're actually a
guy full of testosterone you'll get so
desperate you'll just ask some pig one
day like look it's been a really
long time just [ __ ] help me out
please and you get your swag back after
the bad one
this guy man man this is like are you
excited though this is like a
psychological breakthrough i feel like
i feel like honestly in the last year
royce this show has become
has has done several like scientific
experiments and i think this show is
almost borderline science based at this
point
it is it is i think science would be the
you know what mike
i could study this show in a couple of
years and they'll go like yeah there's
things to be learned from this show
should we wear lab coats
i feel like if we were lab coats people
would take us a little bit more
seriously
okay fine but here's the thing we when
we got they have to be vault-tec lab
coats